[Music]
i never had a neighbor like that in
california that watched for me i don't
know dude my neighbor liked that in
vegas my neighbors are like that yeah
yeah it's different man i know all my
neighbors they all watched my [ __ ] they
were watching my house right now
and my whole block is like [ __ ] u.n i
have every [ __ ] ethnicity on my whole
street it's crazy that sounds terrible i
have hella asians and uh
that's about it yeah mostly
mostly mixed white asian couples like me
and nikki there's a lot of interracial
couples yeah it's a [ __ ] travesty if
you ask me
travesty and the other way my friend
diluting the bloodline
you're polluting her blood
what am i doing to my for my race
it's okay cause we're not having kids
because uh thank god
we don't need more halfers in this world
huh halfers not trying to make future
colonizers
okay here we go three two one action a
michigan woman
won a 500 000
lottery prize
on accident what how i want those kind
of accidents right
so she um she was going
to go pick up some scratchers which she
always does
you can already judge her go ahead you
already are
she's a scratcher i love scratching my
my grandpa was a like daily walk to the
liquor store get lotto type of did he
win anything
no sometimes he went like 20 bucks
though yeah that's like that's a good
day i want a hundred bucks off a shotgun
uh that's right it's gambling it's a
rebate you want a hundred bucks yeah
uh at 7-eleven that's dope actually so
it was worth it i think i spent over 500
but you know i 100 so my grandma always
reinvests it right so it's like if she
wins anything she just buys more
scratches with it yeah i think that a
lot of people do that um so she always
purchases her tickets from the same
store and was planning to stop there on
the way home to get what she what's
called a cash world ticket
she she accidentally made a wrong turn
however and had to take a different
route home so then she stopped at a gas
station along the way breaking her
routine like a different gas station yes
sir she stops at at a bp station and
then selected the cash world times 10
ticket
and when she went home she scratched the
ticket off thought she won a grand and
she was going to use the money towards
the trip that she had coming up in a few
months and so she decided to put the
ticket away and cash it when her trip
got closer
the player then said it was three months
before she realized her ticket was worth
500 [ __ ] thousand dollars
goes to the lottery office to cash it
thinking that she's gonna get some trip
money and they're like hey you won five
hundred thousand dollars
and uh yeah pretty surreal so she
thought she won a thousand she thought
she's only one thousand why is there
like she can't see the one
like it was a five she's 61. she didn't
scratch it all the way
yeah maybe it's one of those like times
times 10 scratcher where there's like a
bonus thing in the corner but she can't
do the math yeah and it's like whatever
it is you got there it's like times 50
or whatever you know
i always get those if i get those and i
see it's like whoa i could win a million
dollars right now if i get these
cherries lined up and then it's like you
didn't win anything
you get any cherries i have the worst
luck with all that [ __ ] slot machines
the [ __ ] teddy bear grabber
all of that [ __ ] man scratches i never
win [ __ ] you got to break your routine
and just try again get more scratchers
dude you're not working hard enough
brother just take a go to terribles on
the way back
get a bunch of scratches get a scratcher
or two i did once get a 20 bill in a
public swimming pool
nice i was swimming that's lucky and it
was kind of floating like this sideways
on the thin side and i was like it was
your 20 dollar bill no i took it i was
like oh [ __ ] it's 20 bucks and i put my
pocket in your water pockets in your
water
that took away luck for the next 20
years for you that's why you shouldn't
have picked that up you didn't pick that
up you'd have a scratch right holding
out you're like not today
you should know this your mother is a
buddhist you should know this
she did tell me don't pick up twenty
dollar bill in a swimming pool
never heard that saying before have you
guys seen that machine where it's like
those little bricks it's like electric
bricks yeah stacker stacker dude and
then it's like you push a button and it
goes like it's totally rigged
yeah and then you hit it exactly on the
dot and it pushes it over when you're
like [ __ ] rich it's like dude i'm
about to i'm licking my lip for much to
win a [ __ ] ass you always skip that
you skip that first prize and you're
always like oh i'm gonna get the next
prize don't you the grand big prize i'll
get a nintendo switch dude for free yeah
if you guys came up on half a million
dollars what would you do half a million
dollars yeah half a million dollars
at all
exactly yeah all of it
i hate that it automatically goes to
just the brain oh yeah immediately flush
another [ __ ] toilet
what else to warm myself
we probably try to make it uh buy more
crypto while it's going down
i'd probably reinvest it in more tickets
it's a lot of money but it's also not
[ __ ] you money or retirement money but
it is a [ __ ] ton of money well that's
the mentality that you have during it's
like wow [ __ ] you money yeah yeah if i
if i keep on watering it
it will become [ __ ] you that is the
mentality yeah you gotta reinvest it
dude
get more tickets i might just blow it if
i like came up on it real fast like i
didn't work for it yeah then i think i
might emotionally be down to blow it
real fast as well
because i've like done the other where
it's like you earned a lot of money and
then you try to invest and then you even
trying to do that like lost a lot of my
you know what if i come up on hell money
i might just spend it
poking like a luna man yeah i'm talking
about that buddy like i might get like a
sick car because that's not gonna take
500 000 yeah it might take like uh might
take like 80 grand no it could take it
could take 500 thousand dollars
not that kind of thing like regular six
for like regular people like uh do you
have a wish list like that's just ready
to go when you come up with the cash nah
nah i'm sure you do i think that's my
problem i don't have i don't want
anything yeah same like i just want
better positions of cool [ __ ] that i
like i wish i had that problem
you like you like toys there's like
three cars that i would buy immediately
what are they oh really one of them is a
67 chevelle lame
and the other one is uh this it's an
old-school like truck it's a c10
silverado
both of those are probably like i don't
know like 100 150 maybe
and then uh
any one of the porsche gt series like
gt3 or gt2 any one of those guys why are
you getting cars that everyone [ __ ]
can have i wanna i want a [ __ ]
batmobile you want a delorean which one
the old school one that looks like a
tank the keaton one bro oh the eaten one
is the best one that's the best one and
it's like probably 80 grand that's it
yeah it's not that bad even the one that
has the shield that goes
on
the [ __ ] bomb comes out you don't
want the uh adam westbound
i do think that's tight
but
it's funny but i'm not gonna you know
chicks aren't gonna try to suck my dick
walking out of that thing you'd be
surprised dude for the comedian to go
and buy the adam west batmobile and roll
up and i guess he just won a lot that's
you not bad but i wanna i wanna be i
wanna look like a badass you know what
i'm saying because then chicks want to
all have sex with you and you're getting
outside of the michael keaton battle
building but you're married is this
coming from the guy that had a mini
cooper for like half his life yeah i
love minnie cooper
yeah do you have you seen your talent
job dude did you get the mini cooper as
a
12.
just just genuinely likes it and you're
just like it was a joke though i was i i
first got into it as a bit and then i
loved the car so you bought it as a
[ __ ] but you fell in love with no i
test drove it as a [ __ ] yeah he came in
he was like i was like tall guy in the
middle it was like this while he was
driving
if only that's the weird thing about it
they're so roomy inside it's actually
crazy i couldn't believe it i actually i
don't think i've ever been in that mini
cooper isn't that just called
a coupe what they used to be minier like
the original british european ones yeah
they're tiny
they made them for americans for sure or
whatever now they're just trucks called
mini coopers
big cooper
no
michael keep mountain bill because it
gets the [ __ ] wet yeah that's a
confirmed fact my wife talks about when
you say the vision i mean like the 40
year olds now though
honestly it's just nerdy dudes who like
it because yeah my wife would [ __ ]
there's no there's no amount of times
she would not roll her eyes if i if i
drove home in that thing but that
should dry up every time she would like
be like this for [ __ ] permanently her
eyes
like this that's what i'm saying it's
just about the [ __ ] thing for you
rolling your eyes at you but i don't
give a [ __ ] because i think it's [ __ ]
sick you can put eminem on the license
plate and then she'll love it yeah
eventually she'll let the license you
got to get the frame too with eminem's
face yeah that's not bad but
that's my plan i'm getting a [ __ ]
batmobile that's it though it's not that
expensive so it's like whatever how much
do you think that is like i said i
looked it up it was like i saw one on
ebay like 85 g's or some [ __ ] oh dude i
[ __ ] walked up to the caesars casino
and put it all on black jesus 500 g's
well i guess they would take that bet
easy come easy go dude that's my life
you wouldn't even just maybe put like
400 000 down
what do you think happened to luna bro
yeah i'm not going to stop being who i
am it's who i am live and die
don't change him
you know what i would do i was already i
said the same thing i was like wait a
second
i'm gonna okay i will hold i would hold
thirty thousand dollars
why thirty yeah so i could pay my
mortgage every month
for one year very soon one year
for one year versus just paying off the
house yeah yeah
[ __ ] that dude
i would save like a thousand dollars too
one thousand yeah so i can get like a
lifetime of training from nick
that's that's all it costs dude no
[ __ ] way bro hey jesus you don't have
to pay them yeah dude i'm trying to
respect the game just throw me a couple
of dick sucks coming out for life i'm
throwing a thousand dollars for the rest
of my life yeah this lifetime deals all
the time you know i just google how to
get knocked out
oh it's not like my system though it's
not like my i'm gonna take it back okay
how dare you whoa what the [ __ ] what i
like to do i put my hands down here
sticking my chin out like this
what would you do with 500 2000 with 500
g's yeah that's something boring i want
a house so i'd probably like buy a go
buy a house
that's the most practical thing yeah i
mean i would i would maybe i'd spend
like a hundred thousand of it on like
fun stuff or whatever what oh what oh
what [ __ ] guns an hour
there we go should buy a house at
probably like california somewhere just
because like this is where the rest of
my life was
like that's a down payment bro
yeah a down payment yeah isn't ammo hell
expensive considering like how like
quickly
i just bought like 500 rounds for like
300 or 200 yeah 300 bucks or so it's
like 50 cents a round yeah that's
expensive or what nine million two two
three yeah so you'd only go like 50 000
rounds for like 100 grand yeah yeah
that's if i just bought the same thing
though but i'd probably diversifying
some other stuff yeah damn i still got
ammo from ages ago yeah don't tell me
something i gotta [ __ ] do you guys
sell me something i have ammo from ages
ago too but when i see it go down it
makes me nervous and go buy more yeah
that's the idea gotta constantly cycle
the supply do you guys have emergency
food and water i do i do i have a
backpack as well what of emergency
everything oh yeah just a backpack
though
just depend on the house i actually
bought it on amazon during [ __ ] cobin
because remember how everyone was
talking about like there's gonna be a
shortage and we're gonna go [ __ ] fall
out right so i was like not on my watch
so i went to one backpack please
sustain me for one and a half days
so it's a backpack and it has [ __ ]
emergency kit it has a [ __ ] flare it
has all this [ __ ] it has bullet wound
kid inside everything the bullet one kid
i went premium dude
is it is it radiation proof
oh [ __ ]
you